[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space i'm back after
two days of vacation and i have an
amazing
uh night of episodes for you guys
tonight
we're starting with a dick discussion
with bill gate
uh who's interested in physics of course
he's been a guest on the show before
and then around 9 or 9 30
p.m eastern time tonight or maybe not
maybe eight i don't know uh whenever
this show ends we're gonna do a
review of the movie joker an amazing
movie i've been very impressed i just
went to see it
we're gonna do that tonight a bit have
you been watching the joker
no i think i have more important things
to do than watch uh
what is that batman or superman
it is it is in the batman universe
all right so let's get started and as a
reminder to our crowd
we have a new version of entropy so go
join
the new entropy the layout has been
redesigned it's v 2.0
and that is my favorite place if you
want to send questions or super chats
tonight
and tonight are our survey
is oh it's not refreshing right now but
in any case our survey is
is owen benjamin a nut job because owen
benjamin
has been going around and claiming a lot
of things
he is uh is applying skepticism in the
wildest way possible
in fact denying that nukes exist that
nuclear bombs exist as well as claiming
that we haven't gone on the moon and he
seems to be charmed at the idea of the
flat earth
uh although i don't know that he stands
explicitly for it but in any case he
denies
that we went on the moon talks about a
conspiracy whereby we would have been
made to believe
that we went on the moon through
hollywood movie making essentially
bill gate where do we even begin on
these
well you know i in fact i covered uh
flat earthers about
two three weeks ago and i covered it in
my last uh
show and uh yeah i think
we can summarize flat earthers in a
couple words the first one is that
they have nothing to offer first as far
as science is concerned in other words
they cannot explain gravity
as primarily and uh other cosmic
phenomena
that's one issue that's one side of the
issue the other side of the issue
is that flat earthers are really into uh
conspiracy theories they're strong on
that that's what they talk about 99
of the time now you know uh
i've been labeled a conspiracist you
know i i've been uh ever
you know starting with lincoln uh james
garfield
uh you know um
kennedy's uh all the way to these two
guys these two bozos uh um
assange and uh ed snowden you know those
are all government operations
so you know i i've got a little bit of
history on
uh conspiracies but as far as uh taking
that and saying that nasa never sent
uh you know anyone into to the moon for
example
one issue another one uh they say that
there are no
no satellites communications are done
with
balloons and with underground cables you
know i mean i think these people are
taking it to
a little too far absolutely some people
were reporting on the regular chat that
entropy is down that's because zeddes
has been sending you guys the wrong
links that does you must refresh
your entropy link we are now on entropy
2.0
now you were talking about the gravity
problem in the flat earth model
uh to some extent you can take the flat
earth model
as a big joke essentially i don't know
if that's because i'm just
out of the out of the joker movie i see
jokes everywhere but there's a form of
humor
there's a form of humor in in
re-questioning everything
and trying to come up with alternative
model i believe that
one model i've looked up for gravity in
the flat earth
is that essentially we are on an
accelerating plate
that's going toward the evans and the
acceleration of it
is tan uh whatever g
is so we are essentially on the in an
innovator
9.8 meters per second square if you look
at the second
uh gif that i sent you over there o2
and you'll see no the second one that's
the first one if you look at the second
one
here yeah this one 9.8 meters per second
square
they're saying that there's dark energy
dark matter or something whatever god
pushing the earth upwards at an
acceleration rate of 9.8 meters per
second square
and one one fellow pointed out which i
thought was a good criticism of this
notion that these people have it's that
you know assuming you know it's not the
apple that fell on newton's head but
you know the earth that came up to meet
the apple uh
that means the earth has been
accelerating at 9.8 meters per second
square for the last billions and
billions of years
right and that means right now we should
be traveling faster than the speed of
light
because it this acceleration is
permanent it's every day
you know and so if the earth is being
accelerated
that means uh and we've been
accelerating i don't know for at least a
couple billion years i would say
you know that means uh the earth is now
should be traveling faster than the
speed of light
yeah i mean but that's a good question
uh in terms of the relativistic
experience of uh of the accelerationist
field under gravity
uh how does that work as we get
closer to the speed of light would we
feel less acceleration
is that how it works or would
essentially the inner
is it the energy that matter the energy
invested in the acceleration
for the feeling of acceleration or is it
the uh the absolute value of the speed
difference in per
acceleration term well we have to look
at it as
you know this acceleration is happening
every second
because we're talking about uh little g
which is nine point here on earth it's
9.8 meters
per second square they don't they do not
recognize
anything other than the earth being flat
everything in the universe is
rotating around the earth essentially
you know the stars the
moon the sun so it's the earth that's
accelerating if that's happening
every single second you know right now
we should
by far been exceeding the the speed of
light
and you know i don't know if they're
aware but we cannot travel faster than
the speed of light
very interesting because i was lurking
as well
i was looking to lay out tonight the the
good arguments
against the flat earth although it's
kind of ridiculous to even engage with
it but it's good to have these arguments
in pocket so first argument
the we would have accumulated so much
speed
that we would be traveling at the speed
of flight
now what else what else is the are the
features
of the flat earth model okay look at the
uh now you can put one there the one you
put earlier the
zero one flat earth uh model all right
okay now this is essentially uh in a
nutshell
what they're proposing they're saying we
have a flat earth and on the edges
there's ice okay that's the ice going
around there
and the issue i want you to focus on the
sun and the moon
now we know for a fact that every now
and then we get an eclipse
right and we get an eclipse not only of
the moon but we get an eclipse of the
sun
and so the issue is that in order to get
an eclipse under this model you would
have to look at it from below
upwards that means the moon would have
to get in front of the sun
in one instance and then in the other
instance the sun has to get in front of
the moon because we do have
lunar eclipses and you know
they haven't figured that out you know
you you won't find a
a rational explanation for eclipses
absolutely and that's something
verifiable i mean that's something you
know
we got a little bit of experience on
yeah we got
direct pictures of it i was no thing
that that's one thing i had forgotten
the
in in the flat earth model the sun and
the moon are pretty much the same size
because they are experienced as the same
size in the sky
another argument that i've heard on that
line by owen benjamin is
he says can you imagine that the sun
is x times bigger than the moon and yet
they are the exact same size in the sky
how do we obtain this through random is
essentially invoking
the fact that it's a statistical
abnormality
that they would happen to end up with
the same size in the sky
while having very very different mass
what would you answer to this one
well again it's uh first uh very
unlikely but i mean you know if you're a
flat earther i guess you can justify
anything uh keep in mind that well you
know in that model that
you just showed there uh you know
antarctica
is on the edges right the the the edge
of that plate
that's antarctica right and the it's all
around the earth
it's all made of ice and there are two
arguments here which just blow you away
and that shows you how far these people
have gone
the first argument is that the oceans
don't drain into space
because there's a wall of ice
surrounding the earth that's the first
one
the second one is that well you say well
why can't we just go down there and
verify you know with our own eyes
you know that that there's this wall of
ice and that the ocean stops there right
very simple and they say well because we
have all these government forces which
are
preventing you from reaching the edge of
the earth the globe cuts
and i guess a lot of you know i would
assume if that's true because that's
modern that's our modern version you
know we have all these military guards
in the antarctica right fine
how about 500 years ago i guess the
ships just fell overboard
there were no uh no marines there to
block the
you know our knowledge of antarctica
all right you were also bringing the
definition of flat
uh flat means horizontally level
level even or without unevenness of
surface uh having a surface
i want you to focus on the fact that
these are the uh definitions of ordinary
speech this is what you'll find in the
uh regular dictionary okay okay
so you know and uh the issue is that uh
because you know flat earth uh you might
laugh at them
but we have the flat universers and
those are known as general relativists
they believe that the universe is flat
the general relativist allow for
curvature of the universe
yeah but no because they say uh locally
it's flat it's like the earth you know
the same argument the flat earthers
raise in fact uh you know they say
well how come you know all the train
tracks are straight ahead
and you know the roads are straight and
you say well you know if you look at the
size of the earth you know you're
looking at a very small piece for that
small
distance it's essentially flat and
that's what the
general relativists say as far as the
universe is concerned it's such a big
ball four-dimensional ball that you know
when you look at any piece of it
it's it's relatively flat in comparison
to the entire universe so that's what
they're referring to there
but there's a definition you can see
there you know the next two if you look
at o four and o five
o five say o four has the definition
of this is the definition of general
relativity or what flat means
and they say essentially if you are in
your room
at home and you are in one corner
and you go around your your house in
other words you go
90 degrees 90 degrees 90 degrees and 90
degrees
four times that's why i got that number
four in red there
if you go around it four times and you
end up in the
in your starting point that's known as
flat according to general relativity
if you do it three times like if you if
you go around the equator
uh take a left turn 90 degrees go to the
north pole
take a 90 degrees and you end up back on
the equator well then uh
that's known as non-flat that's roundish
and so they're saying that uh
essentially
flat is something you cover with your
feet you
prove to yourself by uh going around
four times at 90 degrees
and ending up where you started from
that's that's known as flat in general
relativity
and then you have the scientific
definition which is number seven there
if you look it
up that's that's the flat definition
the definition of flat of uh of science
you know it's uh
lacking thickness that's flat and so the
question is how flat is flat
how flat is the is the pancake earth
that the flat earthers propose i mean
how thick is it
so when they say flat are they talking
about a pancake or are they talking
about a plane
like a square you know or whatever
no thickness how flat is flat well uh
i guess that they would tell you it's at
least as thick as
uh as required to explain that we find
volcanoes that when we drill we do
reach points of the mentor i guess
uh so i guess that you they would tell
you that it's at least uh
a few kilometers thick and that we just
never
dug uh further than that
yeah but see it creates a problem
because again the word flat
comes into play here they're known as
the flat earther so they better define
the word flat because it's part of their
label
and the issue is we have you know mount
everest which is not very flat or
doesn't
let the earth be very flat we have the
marianas which is uh very deep in the
pacific ocean the lowest place on earth
and so we have this distance between the
highest place and the lowest place
assuming we have a flat earth you know a
pancake earth let's call it a pancake
earth
and we have this depression we have this
uh high point
the question is again how flat is flat
you know i mean they have to tell you
what they mean by flat
and uh they don't have a definition of
flat they're again they're not
into science they're into conspiracy
theories
all right other arguments that were made
relate to the horizon
and the whole idea that we that boats
the way they disappear
is not compatible with a circular view
of the world
uh which of course i've debunked partly
here on this channel by looking at the
this
flat salts uh salt flats i believe
that's how they're called they are
extremely
flat parts of the earth where salt has
been accumulating from the drying of
water and it leads to seeing essentially
things like a pickup truck disappear
in the arizona compatible with a
curvature of the earth
yeah i mean you know they have all these
arguments about
about you know they can come up with any
scenario
uh you know and the main one or the
i guess the one of the most important
ones they come up with is that if you're
on an airplane you look at the horizon
looks relatively flat
and again you know i travel on on
airplanes and you look at it and there
is a slight curvature but you know it's
very hard
to determine just by eyesight uh
if the earth is flat from an airplane
again because you need to have this
longer view this you know you need to
see more earth and you can do that
you know from space you can do it like
for example from the space station
and they do have pictures of the round
earth from the space station
if there is such a thing as a space
station of course if they deny
that well you know what is what is uh
nasa supposed to do take each member of
the flat earth society out there to
to see it for their own self and prove
to them
individually that the earth is curved
you know
again an airplane uh would have to be
very very high to really see a curvature
that's one issue
the other one is that you know and
airplanes is a good uh
example because you know all these
pilots
they have to use these routes every day
and for all pilots on planet earth to
believe that the earth is round you know
that's uh
quite a bit of consensus there you know
i mean
i guess the cia bribed a lot of people
you know to
to get this uh round earth uh theory out
there you know
now on a final point perhaps which is
more a point that owen benjamin makes
because although i think he's never
really endorsed flatter theory he
endorses
a bunch of of points that are parallel
to flat earth
conspiracies one of the points that he
does make
is we've made up the idea that we went
on the mood
on the moon now you bill gate how do you
convince yourself that we went on the
moon what is the best argument
to show that um i guess we should ex we
should exclude from this the videos
given the potentiality that they would
have been made up what is the best
argument that proves we were on the moon
well let me tell you this again i've
been labeled a conspiracist because you
know i i
believe in that a lot of the politics
has
tons of conspiracies of false flags etc
right now take kennedy's assassination
how long did it last a couple seconds
take uh the towers
9 11 how long did that last you know it
was quick
and compare that now against what these
people are saying about
nasa and programs like the apollo
program
that lasted years involved many people
who
control this over and over right and uh
you know it's very hard when you have
something ongoing like that
uh to to to control that
to control the information first and
second not to be verifiable by
tons of people and that's different than
you know something that happened all of
a sudden assassination you know it's
you know you get caught off guard you
look at it it's a few seconds maybe you
have a movie
and uh you know that's all you got and
so
that's easier to cover up but to cover
up something an ongoing operation like
the apollo program
uh that's very hard to do that's one
issue
the other issue i think is probably more
important again it relates to politics
you know in leica the uh russian dog
went into space when uh gagarin the
first
human to go into outer space tereshkova
the first woman to go out into space
you know the russians claimed the
soviets right they they claimed
all these goals they they you know they
they really
uh you know beat the united states
the united states did not go in there
say no that's all fake it's uh it's uh
soviet propaganda and conversely when
the united states said okay we're going
to go to the moon first they
put the apollo program into place and
they did put a man on the moon
apparently
right mr armstrong the soviets did not
say oh no that's all propaganda it never
happened
and you would think that these enemies
because they are enemies
right they're different mafias one
mafia's in moscow the other one's in
washington these mafias they they
they're gonna try to
do anything to undermine the other side
and here they did neither the americans
in fact the americans panicked because
they said look the russians are already
out into space we haven't even gone up
there these guys have already sent a
human up there
so they were worried and that's why they
put the uh apollo program
you know in place because they were
worried about these soviets gaining
advantage
in space and so for the americans to
treat that and say
you know it did happen and yeah we take
our hats out to the soviets they
they put a man into space you know it
would have been much easier for
washington to say no it
happened so fake it was done in uh
moscow's hollywood
you know and they did they they took it
seriously and vice versa the soviets
took you know
armstrong's stepping on the moon very
seriously as well well that is an
argument
based on absence i mean you could you
could think
that the russians did not criticize but
it was for some other reason i would say
personally the arguments
that uh convince me is the presence of
mirrors on the moon that can be that
have been
installed manually and that can be uh
sent light from the earth as well as the
uh
china pictures of the moon site where
uh people have been using the rover i
think they are pretty convincing that
they are not natural
paths that were driven into the sand
yeah but you know a flat earther is
going to tell you that all that's done
in hollywood it's all done with pictures
you know anything related to pictures
they're going to say it's it's fake
and you know another another issue you
know and that's
not only for flat earthers because there
are a lot of other people who are not
flat earthers who
don't believe that man went to the moon
and one of the arguments uh they raise
or the argument that i raise against
them
is that you know these people find all
kinds of faults the shadows are wrong
the
stars are not in the background uh the
gravity is not the
proper you know they get all these
errors right and i'm saying
one of the problems i've got with that
is that the more errors they find
the less uh believable is their uh
argument because the the directors of
hollywood could not have made
so many errors i mean if the
if if this was done in hollywood you
know the the movie the the pictures
everything if it was done in hollywood
they wouldn't have made so many errors
it's like uh making a movie of the
romans and having someone with a wrist
watch you know uh
the directors look for these things you
know they say hey did you
take your wristwatch rolex off before we
filmed
and they wouldn't have made so many
errors and and so the more
errors they find of man on the moon that
something is not right
the less likely is their argument the
less believable is their argument
another argument we've not mentioned
back on the flat earth
theory is uh
the tides the tides are very hard to
explain
for a flat earther without gravity and
without the mass of the moon pulling
this water up
yeah that's true too uh
newton showed that the tides were caused
by the moon
and if we take that out well you know
again these people are not providing
answers alternative answers to these
questions
uh to gravity to the tides to light i
mean
you know if if they're gonna be
scientific about it
well they they should really give more
answers than just say well it's all the
conspiracy and they don't let us
understand they don't let us see and you
know that's politics
do science you if you want to get your
flat earth theory or hypothesis
across come up with explanations for
among other things what you mentioned
earlier you know nuclear weapons
you know how does the sun work explain
eclipses explain gravity you know
this is what we want but if these people
are just going to say you know it's all
conspiracy and
and they're just going to be naysayers
saying well you know whatever we hear is
is all fake
well you know then if that's fake what
is true
all right this is the issue before we
move on to the subject of radioactivity
we have
a few questions from the crowd uh thank
you so much you guys for using
entropy it is the new platform and i see
that many of you have joined us there
and are sending your super chats there
white supremacist smile
since 20 bucks thank you so much he says
bill what is the two
and three body problem
um two two and three body problem
is the issue that if you take the earth
okay and the moon
you will have an eclipse right the uh
moon goes around the earth and we have
an eclipse with respect to the sun
in other words the the uh moon blocks
the uh sunlight from reaching the earth
okay we all know this
okay so what is the explanation that
relativity has for this
is that the sun weighs down the canvas
the space-time canvas and the earth
weighs down the space-time canvas and
that's because
and that's the reason the moon goes
around now what is the problem the
problem is you cannot extrapolate that
scenario to uranus uranus you have this
uh
moon that goes over the poles
towards the sun
and so if the sun waves the canvas
downwards
and uranus weighs the canvas downwards
the the moons of uranus
should go just like our moon it should
go around your equators
that's not the case for uranus it goes
around the poles
and in the case of pluto we have the
same thing it's got its moon sharon
and sharon forms a bullseye
pattern as seen from the sun in other
words
instead of going around the equator
right it goes
around the poles but in a uh bullseye
pattern as seen from the sun
and again that that means that pluto
would have to uh push
the canvas outwards uranus would have to
push it
um sidewards and
the earth would push it downwards and so
einstein's mechanism for gravity
cannot be extrapolated to three-body
system it can only work with two body
systems at least in
in our solar system very interesting i
was not aware of this
how did they explain them the uranus
vertical positioning of the satellite
uh they let it die by pocket veto they
they simply don't deal with these issues
really nobody
no there's no explanation for why it is
that way
no absolutely not of course not that's
that's why the
they cannot have this to uh they cannot
extrapolate the two body system they can
explain easy you know
uh we all we all can imagine a bowling
ball weighing down the canvas
and a little marble going around we can
all imagine that
now do it with three do it with three
now
and you won't be able to do it it's
simply impossible
especially uh if you look at uh our
solar system it doesn't work that way
well that that is quite shocking i have
it's it's mind-bending to try to think
of the canvas being uh
space bent uh the space-time being bent
in three dimensions very hard to
to conceptualize without imagining it
back to a 2d
world but i didn't know that there was
no explanation
it's uh it's somewhat worrying but is
there anything that
forces these uh these orbital paths
to be aligned really to be flat in other
words
aren't you kind of a flat earther and
expecting relativity
to force i'm just kidding
here but you're a flat arbiter
you're you're being a flat orbiter and
by the way people on the chat are
requesting that you close your discard
because i think we're hearing some of
the noises uh hopefully you get a chance
to uh
if i can if i can uh let me give me one
second so that i can get rid of my uh
discord here
all right no problem while you do that
i'll read some other questions
erling says host a debate between vegan
gains versus
eduard dutton i'm up for it
but edward dutton has his own channel i
suspect that if they
wanted to host it they could do it on
his channel
that being said if they need a
third-party moderator i'm not close to
the id
uxg3 styles says oh look
an old drug addict and a cuban [ __ ]
you're hurting my feelings he's calling
me a drug addict
and
that is very evil oh my god all right
and pregnant trout says thumbs up
thumbs up the pregnant trout is back uh
did you follow this old crat escapade
that i had where i was arguing with a
youtuber named kraut
who was making scientific videos that
were used to
to justify leftist view and i was
debunking
them and at some point he claimed that
trouts were
pregnant that the the pregnancy the
length of the pregnancy of a trout was
very short
and i was laughing my ass off because
there's no pregnancy in droughts
no i don't deal with those issues okay
no you don't
it's like the joker movie it's not your
thing
pineapple platypotemus says pendulum
exhibits
in museums prove the earth is wrong
round really can you can you prove that
the earth is round
using uh pendulums well
it's related to gravity and again um
if you have a different version of
gravity which in this case is that they
say
the earth is accelerating upwards with
quotations whatever upwards means in
space
well yeah i mean you i guess you can uh
justify almost anything again a flat
earther is a person who uh
is gonna find all kinds of excuses and
all the excuses will be
related to uh conspiracy theories that
you know the information is being kept
away from us
so you know uh this gentleman is correct
uh
if you look at uh focals pendulum which
is in france there
you know it moves and it moves thanks to
the fact that the earth is round and uh
the center of gravity is in the center
of the ball
so to speak okay if we have a flat earth
well i don't know how you would explain
this pendulum even if the
uh there's an acceleration of the earth
upwards again whatever upwards means
i'm not sure you could explain the
pendulum there you know very interesting
it's up to them to come up with
an explanation for focal's pendulum you
know for example
how does that look a foucault pendulum
let me google it so it's a
it's a kind of circle like that uh
how does that work yeah well
again it's uh it's the movement
of this pendulum with respect to gravity
you know it's uh
under under the rope model i can explain
it to you very easily you know
every atom of that ball is connected to
every atom on earth
so i'm trying to to get to see one in
in the works operating
uh i don't see much move
here it decreases because of the
friction of the air
and you make the system bigger and
there's still friction of the air
all right so essentially they claim that
this was
sufficient to prove globe earth
let's get into the the question of
radioactivity
because one other thing that owen
benjamin denies
is uh radioactivity doesn't deny but it
denies that uranium
can be used to build nuclear bombs so
how do or should we conceive of
radioactivity how does that work
well you have the uh quantum version
and i can only give you my alternative
rope version and they're very different
the quantum version is that you have
a nucleus and
some some elements like uranium are
spontaneously get rid of beta alpha and
beta particles alpha particles
think of it as simply a helium atom
which means that it's got two protons
two neutrons right
and so it just expels
you know uranium atom will expel or get
rid of
um what is known as an alpha particle
a uh a helium atom and then you have the
beta
decay which is you know that gets rid of
electrons
uh a neutron essentially has the
mass of a proton and an electron put
together and essentially what you're
doing is getting rid of the electron
from the nucleus
that's that's the theory the problem
i've got
uh with the quantum version with the
quantum explanation
mechanism is that to begin with it's
it's what i had with peter when we had
our
little debate there and that's that you
know
they they can they cannot draw for me an
atom
any atom uh even the simplest the
hydrogen atom
why because they can draw a uh proton
which is a particle made of three
particles allegedly
three quarks and they can draw an
electron what they cannot draw or tell
me
is what keeps that electron bead bound
to the nucleus that's what i want to
know and they can't do that they never
have in the last hundred years
and so before we can get an explosion
of a helium atom of an alpha particle
they have to show me what the uranium
atom
looks like and they can't do that on the
other hand on the rope model
if you look at uh well before we get
into the rope model
i wanted to understand uh do we have a
mechanistic explanation of
why these atoms release this particle
is it just that the the force of the
nucleus becomes too unstable and
unsustainable when there's too many
neutrons too many protons
how does that work well in under quantum
it's just done by uh hand waving it's
it's done with a magic wand
under the rope model you know i i do
explain it very easily
uh you know if you have uh for example
take take the hydrogen atom
right if you take you deuterium
it's got a a neutron in
the nucleus so you have a proton a
neutron
and an electron on the outside
supposedly right and now you go into
tritium
and now you have two neutrons well what
happens
under under the rope model it's very
easy because it's uh what you're doing
is
you're compressing more matter into
a uh in a in a it's like think of a
balloon and you're putting three
balloons inside
a balloon well if you put only one
balloon in there
well i can you know nested balloons it
can handle it
you put do balloons it's gonna be
strained if you put three balloons
it's gonna be radioactive it's gonna try
to
it's gonna be unstable but under the
quantum version
there is no explanation it just is it
just they just say tritium is
radioactive because god made it that way
so to me
and the problem we have the problem we
have the problem we have uh
jf is that under the quantum
model uh you say what's the purpose of
neutrons why did god create neutrons and
they say oh very simple
the neutron is used there to keep
protons apart you know because protons
are all positive they would
they would push each other away and so
we if you put a neutron in between well
it kind of acts as a referee right but
in the case of hydrogen there's only
one proton in the case of deuterium
there's one proton and one neutron
right and uh if the purpose of neutrons
is to keep protons apart why did god put
you know a neutron inside deuterium why
did it put
two inside tritium
so there's no there's no reason they
just say it is it is well
the thing is i don't think that it is
the claim of physicist that
neutrons have a purpose it's just that
the forms that we see in the universe
are only those that are stable
and of course a a proton only nucleus
with many protons would be
unstable that's why we see nucleus that
have neutrons
why would it be unstable i mean again
there's no explanation
they just say it is but they don't tell
you what cause
what physically causes a uh
an atom a heavy atom like uranium 92 you
know
protons electrons why would it be
unstable see
see because of the little pluses there's
little pluses that are pushing each
other like this
there's what what little pluses
the plus are are expelling the plus and
the negatives are expelling the
negatives
and the plus and the negative they they
pull on each other
you know you know um you know about p
orbitals right you you've heard there's
an s orbital that covers uh
an atom which is a round one and then
you have the figure eight
which is the p orbitals okay and
the issue it shows you what the problem
is
in quantum mechanics you have a p
orbital
which goes right through the center or
very close to the center of
you know to the nucleus and you say well
hold it the electron is negative right
and we have a
positive nucleus why does why does the
electron get so close and not get sucked
in like a magnet
you know here it goes right through in
fact in some in many cases you'll see
they illustrated the electron going
right through the center of the atom and
out the other end
others simply say well it goes very
close
either case why why doesn't the nucleus
just swallow that electron
what keeps the electron bound to the
atom what keeps the electron
what prevents the electron from being
sucked into the nucleus if the nucleus
is positive and the electron is negative
and they have no explanation they just
say it is so
there is no explanation yeah i mean it's
a it's a good thing to raise
uh i don't know that i had an ever
thought about
conceptualizing it but couldn't we see
the electron as
a never attempting shoot that cannot be
as precise as to collide into the
nucleus
and so because of let's say that the
electron is subject to eisenberg
uncertainty principle in its collision
it never
quite collide well it does collide
because see
a neutron expels during during
beta decay a neutron supposedly expels
an electron because that electron
somehow got stuck to the proton
to neutralize the charges they trapped
the electrons
i didn't know that but how do you
approach
neutrons in the rope model because i was
looking at this here
uh you have an atom model where you have
the threads
i believe that the threads represent
negative and positive
uh electricity forces no
no no there's no negative or positive
all we have is ropes those are ropes
and what you have is the thread is only
in a
in the blue area in the center of the
circle okay so
so the threads one thread goes around
and forms that
red uh circle that forms the
boundary or what i call the electron
shell
and then the proton which is the center
is made of threads from
every atom in the universe so the rope
stops
at the electron shell at the circle
okay you can see those are ropes and
then what continues
are threads now where are the neutrons
in there
well the neutron the neutron uh
unfortunately you didn't uh
you didn't ask that question before the
show i would have sent you a
uh a picture of the new trump but i'll
see if i can explain and you'll
probably understand it just think of
just think of the
because it's neutral there it has no
such thing as charge
okay remember charge in
in our model is that the atom expands
and contracts doing quantum jump
okay so what happens at the place where
the rope
forks out and forms the atom there's a
little uh friction there you know it
unwinds and winds unwinds and winds
constantly
and if you add all those if you
aggregate
all those areas around an atom that's
what we call
charge okay each one of those is each
one of those points is a charge
the neutron doesn't have charge so the
question is how do we do
neutron well the neutron it doesn't have
the it doesn't the the rope does
not fork out that's what it is the ropes
continue straight
to the other side in every direction and
so
if the proton is a convergence of
electric threads or just threads a
neutron is a convergence of ropes all
the ropes just continue there is no
circle as you see there ah
so the threads remain together
and so that's why we don't distinguish
an electric charge we have
both red and blue components all at the
same place
yeah in other words the ropes continue
straight it's a convergence of ropes
and that's why it doesn't have charge
because there is no quantum
jump in a neutron wow
i i should have sent you the picture
maybe i'll send you the picture
afterwards at least
you'll understand
all right it was real in my mind sends a
question he says is the rope slash
fabric you describe existing within the
caliber
yaw space i don't know if you know that
term
yeah yeah space well
again these people are
obsessed with mathematics and we do
physics
physics does not care about all these
equations uh we're just interested in
understanding
mechanisms okay so you know
we do we do not like to step over the
boundary into mathematics
because uh again that's a place that
does not correspond to physics any more
than physics corresponds to
equations you know they can do their
equations over there but when they come
to the physical
interpretations that's where we have a
clash with the mathematicians
because these people are trying to
interpret what they see in the lab or
or they're interpreting their equations
and they give you
a bogus explanation for how the universe
works
you know they sell you a particle can be
at two places at once
what do you mean or they'll give you the
uncertainty
principle they'll say you know the
electron can be anywhere you know we
don't we can't
uh figure out the position and the
the uh motion the momentum
of of a particle and they go through all
this stuff
that has nothing to do with physics but
they give you that physical
interpretation
based on what they you know calculated
or what they
think they observed in the lab but it's
very easy if you
if you go to the standard model of
quantum mechanics if you look it up
on wikipedia you'll find that they don't
have a picture of any of the particles
they've never seen a particle and they
never will because there are no such
things as particles
you know so if you say well what does a
higgs look like
you know what does an electron look like
they don't know they don't even know
what an atom looks like they say they
took pictures that they filmed they
interviewed them personally and they no
one can draw an atom for you because
they don't know what an atom looks like
and if they did draw an atom all they
would have to explain is
how that little bead stays you know
faithful to the nucleus
before it ionizes or goes into
electricity and that's what they can't
do they
never have explained what keeps the
electron bound to
the protons all right i was googling
what is the caliber your space i don't
know about this at all
can i be your manifold apparently that's
a 2d
slice of a 6d manifold too complex for
me
above my pay grade a pineapple
platypotamus says
does your guest recommend richard
feynman videos
yeah i recommend the magnetic one
especially when they ask him to explain
how a magnet works and
uh rich you know is not able to do so
and uh rich also has a couple other
things which i
i like which is he made statements he
said no one understands quantum
mechanics
and people don't don't listen to what he
said because you talked to a lot of
people
in fact i got a quora article in which
someone
criticized and said yeah they do
understand see if we have all this
technology
the computer you're using is thanks to
quantum mechanics and you know they go
through all this stuff
they don't realize that you know these
people are telling them
in their faces that they don't
understand quantum mechanics
and i'm not only talking about rich i'm
talking about people like leo
uh suskind uh he's uh from stanford
university
he tells them you know we don't
understand quantum mechanics
and these people are listening to that
they say character we know you
understand
it because otherwise we wouldn't have
the technology and that's that's all
they can say
you know gps proves relativity and uh
computers prove quantum mechanics that's
that's all they understand
they don't realize that technology has
nothing to do with an a
physical interpretation leo scan is very
sad
fascinating i've seen a speech of him
where he was talking about
our universe our observable universe
being only one branch of potentially
a big bang that would have been much
bigger that would have
resulted in many such branches do you
believe in
such a thing as the fact that our
observable universe
is essentially isolated as a as a
consequence of the speed limit of light
the fact that we're in an isolated
bubble and that there is
other observable universes out there
yeah of course i think the universe is
much greater much greater than what we
can see
so they talk about two universes one is
the observable universe
and then all the others are supposedly
you know uh
parallel universes even though they all
came out of the big bang so
you know whatever they mean by that
again they never pinpoint
uh the exact thing because they consider
all that philosophy
they say no we dismiss that as
philosophy i call that physics physics
is
trying to understand how this universe
works and if if it's
like they say that we came out of an
explosion
right that occurred 13.8 billion years
ago
then the observable universe is what we
can see
and then what's out there what do we
call the rest of it and they say well
that's not part of our universe because
it doesn't matter anyways because we
can't see it we can't test that we can't
do anything with it so we'll just
consider it as if
it's inexistent yeah and that's not true
and if you try to make sense of it they
say you're doing philosophy
yeah it's hard because science is
defined around our capacity to observe
but yet it's almost impossible and i
would argue impossible
that it just so happens that the
universe we see
is all there is and so personally i also
think
uh the big bang must have led to
much bigger than what we see but we'll
never know
probably alexander kohaniak says
how will we know how will we know that
the size of the universe outside of the
observable bound
no i i'll tell you that we will know
that there was no big bang
we can't know that for sure how will we
know that
uh perfectly easily take nothing and try
to tell me how you create
something even if you're god right i'll
give you all the power all the
superpowers you want
and you need to create something from
nothing show me the mechanism
well that that's an attack of the
lawrence cross position and framing but
you could imagine
easily a big bang not starting from
nothing nothing starting from something
ah starting from something well we
already had something then
then we can create something from
something from nothing you don't deny
space expansion
yes i do of course there's no such thing
as space expansion because space
is nothing and nothing cannot expand
only things can expand
but the uh the change of color the the
frequencies that as we look further they
get more red or more blue depending on
the distance and depending on how much
the light that that's coming to us has
been
made to be more and more red how do you
explain
yes yeah very easy uh
okay here uh here's a rope okay
famous rope okay okay now you're looking
at it head on
right let's see if i can do that like
that okay
uh-huh there
okay okay so so imagine now two galaxies
right and they're far apart
okay yeah the farther they are apart
the rope is going to
uh become the links are gonna become
longer
okay because there's kind of a torch a
force
no no listen if if you have if you tie a
rope
right uh your grandmother's rope between
a clothesline
okay if you go farther away from the
edges
like towards the center the the links
will become a little longer
okay and that's here on earth imagine
gazillions of miles now out there in
space
so for sure the farther a galaxy is from
us
the rather it better be on the other
hand
on the other hand the blue shifted
galaxies which are
in our local group like andromeda is
coming towards us
uh according to you know the official
word why because
it's blue shifted why because it's close
by
two two million miles away to uh
what is it uh 2.2 i think it is
uh you know well it's close by
yeah whereas the other galaxies the
other galaxy are very far away
and the ropes of course uh you know
if if i were to follow the rope uh from
an atom here all the way to that galaxy
over there
it should little by little the links
should become
longer longer links red
very simple so you think it's we don't
we don't need
speed for this essentially the doppler
shift model and
the traditional model would tell us that
it's absolutely random the fact that
this galaxy is headed toward us
and that it's blue shifted you say it's
not random it's related to the fact that
it's close to us
well uh there i think there's gonna be
some gravity at this
level you know the galactic level uh the
local group has like 56
galaxies that they found and all these
galaxies
are bound to each other again i'm saying
they're
physically connected all the atoms over
there are connected to us
so that's the gravity and uh you know
when you have this massive galaxy
i think that at that level they pull
each other
in a gravitational attraction okay so
there is some
drifting towards us so it's very likely
that uh andromeda is moving towards us
what i'm saying is we have to
distinguish uh
what um relativity says that they claim
that the
universe is blowing apart and that's how
they came up with big bang
i'm saying that's not true the farther a
galaxy is from
the earth the redder it should be
because the ropes
are you know the links on the ropes
should be longer
and a longer link means that it's red
uncle jesus says what
force is pulling the links further apart
farther apart
just drifting it's just you know
for example the harvard tower experiment
they measured uh a change in frequency
as the
you know the beam went out went from the
bottom of the tower to the top of the
tower so they were able to measure that
change in frequency and they were
astounded by that but it's not
astounding be if you take a rope
and you take it from sourcing outwards
out into space
you know that link without any movement
just the link should become
longer the farther you get away from
earth
all right very interesting um
we did have some comments to do on
radioactivity
uh i'm getting some echo from you i
don't know if your speaker is too strong
perhaps you can let me lower it a little
bit
all right perfect uh tauren mckay before
we get
to our final comments on radioactivity
says if by observing a photon we can
alter its actions within space
and time could we communicate by
altering photons
in morse code essentially plucking the
ropes
it describes what okay that was one
question so let's start with this one
well i think altering photons is
essentially what we do with fiber optics
right
well again we have to see
we we have to find out what a photon is
under the rope model it's just a link of
the rope this is a photon here
that that's a photon you know
and uh these people say well it's zero
uh
zero mass zero volume so so what are we
talking about we have nothing
a photon is nothing it has no mass no
volume no anything but they use it you
know they
represent it with a little ball they say
well it's a ball
and when they need the uh frequency and
the wavelength then they put a
you know the uh james maxwell's famous
uh transverse wave and and that's not an
object either it's just a bunch of
vectors
and so we have either vectors or a
little ball
and and when you say well you know i
want to know the physical interpretation
they say
that's philosophy
it's like you never get a physical
interpretation from quantum not one that
you can rationalize
that's why they say you know nobody
understands quantum mechanics because
they never were able to
rationalize it all right
dieter johnson on the regular chat
accusing me of having
zero per nordic genetics well [ __ ] you
dieter tauren mccabe says why does bill
assume that atoms
look like or act like physical objects
his assumptions are based on his eyes
and ends which are not adapted to view
atoms or physically interact with them
well we start with the definition of
what an object is and we say that
physics cannot be done without
objects if there's absolutely nothing in
the universe just empty space
just vacuum there's nothing going on so
physics starts at the principle the what
i call the golden principle you can't do
physics without an object
so anyone who does physics without
objects is doing religion he's doing
spiritualism
he's re he's essentially introducing
spirits in that same space and say i'm
gonna move concepts around
because you know i can't see it i can't
touch it i can't touch light i can't see
light you know the mediator of light
i can't see gravity i can't see the
mediator or touch it
so i'll assume it's a spirit it's
they'll just do and they they work with
mass they work with energy
with all these concepts but they but you
never see the meat you never see an
object
not even not in mathematical physics and
so yeah i do assume that
atoms are things
a thing is that which has shape and
you know i can draw my atom uh quantum
can't draw
its atom all right alexander kohani
accents 10 bucks he says
uranus is tilted orthogonally
related to the sun as well not
only its satellite could it be possible
that this is only
a temporary situation caused by a cosmic
event yeah i mean uh
my point was on on uranus my my point
was that
if if you can't uh extrapolate the three
body system that we have like
earth moon and sun you can't extrapolate
that the uranus
and what is it over on that goes around
the the poles
or to uh uh pluto and sharon you can't
extrapolate it because
if the sun weighs downwards and we're
gonna have that you know the equator of
the sun
right it's weighing down in that
direction
south considering you know the equator
if you look at pluto uh you know you
have this bullseye pattern and that
means pluto would have to push
outwards for sharon to go around in the
way it does
and that's the problem the problem is
the three-body system
now uranus yeah of course it's possible
that
uh something happened like you know
venus also venus uh
rotates very slowly and in the opposite
direction
so you know something happened in uh in
all these cases
and by the way you know uh my theory on
that which uh
is good to know because it is very
different uh
the earth and all the rocky planets
they were stars
the irony the only way you the only you
believe that the earth
was a star before all
all all round
differentiated rocky planets star
um moons etc
were stars the only way you can get
roundness
and differentiation is in a mechanism
such as what's happening in the sun
inside the sun right now you have to
have compression
of the atoms uh starting from the
outside inwards you got to have
hydrogen being pushed in constantly
being
merged through um fusion
and that's how you create uh heavy
elements such as iron in the center
followed by silicon less you know less
dense
less massive atoms followed by the gases
and that's if you look at mars if you
look at venus if you look at the
the earth they're all made like that
they're all made with
rot with a heavy elements in the center
followed by lighter elements and
eventually by in the case of mars and
venus by co2
that's that's the that's the
construction of a star
only venus was a star mars was a star
and they've been around billions and
billions of years way beyond
the big bang you cannot imagine a
mechanism that only relies on gravity
and non-fusioned elements
that would explain the the roundness of
the earth
absolutely not but i would love for
someone to rationalize it for me
otherwise
i think that the earth used to be a star
it was compressed and that's why it's
differentiated and that's why it's round
almost perfectly round that's a star
that that's that's the definition of a
star
well uh i mean it's easy to imagine
but just imagine to just imagine a
planet that is on an axis
like this and there's a little sand air
sound ears and here's an
air so essentially a longitudinal planet
uh if the the forces of gravity are
pulling
this this dust toward the middle and
this dust toward the middle
at some point you're gonna get around
just out of uh
random interaction every time a piece of
dust falls
it is more likely to be headed toward
the center but once it's at the center
there's no reason to push it back
out and so even a very uh
even a a stick would eventually
transform into something round if the
gravity force
is strong enough toward the middle
you know why that can't be let me tell
you why uh if you take the
four galilean moons that jupiter has
jupiter is is essentially a sun that
never ignited didn't have the mass to
ignite
neither did saturn you know all these uh
little um
gaseous planets the big ones uh they
were stars that didn't
simply did not have enough mass so what
is the official version the official
version says
which is the nebular hypothesis says
that
uh all these um uh
planets these gaseous planets simply
condensed
uh you know from the matter that was
around the sun
okay if that were true which is
essentially what i'm going to answer it
respect to your question the rocky moons
of jupiter why are they at the same
level as jupiter and why are they rocky
i mean they should be gases as well why
did they turn into rocks
whereas jupiter turned into you know a
gas ball which is what it is see all
these all these uh
all these planets these gaseous planets
they have rocky moons
and and these rocky moons around like uh
you know
ganymede uh jupiter's biggest moon
they're above a certain size because
there
is a lower size at which gravity is not
strong enough and then
therefore they're not round
right and and that happens to uh some of
the asteroids but you take
ceres which is the biggest asteroid it's
perfectly round
and the question you know you get some
of these uh
um uh for example mimas the
the smallest object in the solar system
which is round
you know uh how do you explain that you
can't explain it just you know this
piece of rock that is so perfectly
rounded god
you know uh cut it in into a little ball
no that was it's a sun it was a star
once
a billions and billions trillions of
years ago then you can explain not only
roundness but you can explain
differentiation on the other hand if
you're going to use the mechanism that
you just explained you're saying well
you have this um gas
and other matter that's floating around
and it condenses and the heavier
elements go to the center okay that's
what you were saying
well then we would not have uh next to
jupiter we would not have rocky planets
why are these completely rocky and this
big guy here
is just gas that's easy you don't have
to invoke satellites to come
from the same process as the planets you
can have satellites that have formed
independently and that have then fed
into the orbits of jupiter
yeah that's uh possible but see uh the
way they explain it is not that way they
say that
the way it happened is that you have
collision
here of iron and silicon and whatever
and here of gas
and they were at the same level they
were at the same um distance from the
sun for example right
uh the rocky uh moons of jupiter the
rocky moons of saturn you know they were
there
they were at the same level and so the
question is how did this guy turn into a
piece of gas
a ball of gas and this other guy ended
up being rocky
that's the problem there is a big
problem
all right it was uh always with his
contradictory views with the mainstream
science
when i talk with bill it's the only
moment where i get to defend mainstream
science
i get to be the non-contrarian i love it
it was real in my mind says we have
proven that we alter
photons by observing them within the
double sit experiment
this has the potential for binary
communication
yeah i mean uh whatever your
interpretation of the double suit
experiment
is it does lead to quantum computing
possibilities right
well yeah i got yeah by the way bill i
never
asked you about quantum computing i hate
i hate quantum computers do you too
well the problem is that they use the
word the adjective
quantum there just to say that it
follows you know the uncertainty
principle
and uh the coherence and all the stuff
that they invented in in
quantum the point here is that they
don't understand their own theories
but they use the word quantum simply to
say as an adjective
you know when they say quantum computer
what are they saying they're saying
it follows the rules of quantum which is
that we don't understand it
that's what they're saying in other
words they're not which is a big problem
they've proven the theory
but they're using the adjective of
quantum simply because they're saying
look it follows all these weird things
that we don't understand that's why we
call it quantum computer
yeah that's the big problem of these
things it's that it's
it will be non-logic in the end now it
may have specialized applications in
quantum
in in some form of password encoding
but i think for the vast majority of
what we do with computers we want
answers that are repeatable and always
the same
coughing says there is almost an
infinite number of ropes
but why there is no entanglements
aha entanglement people are always
concerned with entanglement the the
the question they should ask before they
ask about the rope
entangled is whether uh quantum
particles hit each other
you know i mean it's a billiard ball uh
theory
uh you know when when light goes in this
direction the other one goes at 90
degrees
do you know these particles bounce off
each other
see they never ask that same question
for quantum and it's the same problem
well good question i mean it's a problem
intersecting a rays of light
how does it happen and can we actually
uh neutralize a 90 degree
uh ray of light using another 90 degree
rare flight so that the waves cancel
each other
is there such a thing like sound
cancellation but for
light if you ask mr burke
who uh carried out experiments a few
years ago he says yeah
it happens that light bounces off light
he does it with virtual particles
anyone can do it with virtual particles
because those are magical ones that
mathematicians introduce at their
leisure
no light does not bounce off of light
and you can prove this to yourself uh
very easily uh in fact there's two ways
of proving it the first one is you take
light and run it through two magnets and
see
if the magnetic field of the magnet in
any way
deviates the beam of light and
relatively claims that gravity bends
light okay let's prove it let's see if
we can do this
we take a laser in the desert the
longest distance you can imagine
okay in our flat earth it would be
perfectly done
you point out from the you know one side
of antarctica to the other right okay so
you got this laser
okay and now uh and you
pinpoint it you you know you measure it
very carefully and
where the pinpoint is right and now you
put a billion
trucks full of all kinds of garbage on
one side of the beam
well it should bend the beam it should
take it away from that center point
because you put all the trucks full of
all kinds of things you know you put
something very heavy on one side of the
beam it should bend the beam
and it doesn't for sure it doesn't we've
never measured
on earth a difference of speed of light
with
respect to the position of the the
ground versus
the heavens
the problem is you don't have enough
distance to be able to
really determine that remember the moon
which is very far away
is one in about one and a half
light seconds one second for light to
reach the moon
so to speak right and that's
very far away so you can imagine you
can't do that on earth but
there is a way of you know i got a
little experiment for people to do if
they have a little vacuum chamber
you take a beam of light okay you take a
laser for example you point it
at a photo multiplier photo
multiplier what it does it can measure
intensity among other things right it
can measure the intensity of light
so you point it at the laser at the the
laser at the
photo multiplier okay and now you pump
the chamber down
well quantum predicts that if you remove
matter from the chamber the mean free
path of the beam is now better
you should have a higher intensity i
swear by my mother's
my mother's grave that you won't get a
higher intensity if anything it stays
the same or drops
why because under the rope model you're
removing the atoms that are relaying the
signal from the laser
to the photo multiplier all right so
that's based on uh
essentially you are saying if if if
waves of flight were
photons they would collide with the
atoms otherwise
present in the vacuum chamber
right in other words if you have
atmospheric pressure
in other words room temperature room uh
pressure right and you put the laser and
you
send it and send it inside the vacuum
chamber right but at room
pressure and you send the beam to the
photomultiplier you get a certain
intensity
if you pump the chamber down like to the
minus seven or minus eight torr or
whatever
uh you know the you remove matter from
atoms from there so now the beam does
not the photons
they don't have anything to bounce
against now you should have a higher
intensity
i bet you're you're any amount of money
you won't get
uh you know higher intensity but certain
frequencies of
light do get absorbed by matter we see
it because
the sky is blue because of that my
understanding is that
the air on the planet earth the
atmosphere
absorbs some of the red light and that's
why the sky ends up blue
so there is some form of absorption but
it's at specific frequencies
okay so now let's remove the air from
the earth
all around should we get a higher
intensity or lower intensity
light in our faces well we should get a
little
higher and it might not be blue anymore
yeah
right and so now let's do that in a
vacuum chamber that's the same
experiment we remove
matter we should have higher intensity
i'm telling you you will not get a
higher intensity
i guess you just need a big enough
vacuum chamber so that the
relative sparsity of atoms in a gas
can eventually matter because i mean we
conceive of gases
as being very poor in terms of density
of electrical
of electron and uh proton content right
well atoms content
yeah again you know if
atoms absorb light as we say
right then if you remove the atoms that
prevent light from reaching the photo
multiplier
you should have a higher intensity it's
very simple
it's a very simple experiment to run all
right
ruko alexander sends 10 bucks thank you
so much it says bill
in 100 000 years you'll see the rings
around saturn
forming a round satellite big rocks get
rounder the bigger they
are size correlates with roundness i
tend to agree with this
well i i don't i'm saying that in order
to get
roundness and differentiation okay two
things uh roundness and differentiates
that means that
you have layered the the ball is layered
okay
the heavier elements are in the center
followed by lighter elements eventually
by gases
you know that's the structure of any
star and i'm saying
all these planets all the in fact the
moons
a lot of the moons they don't have
atmospheres but they do have this
heavy delight uh structure
and they're all the same and so
i think mother nature or father universe
whoever out there they don't have
a such a sophisticated system all they
have is gravity
that's it they work with gravity and
they can deal with gravity and make
anything round and differentiated
and we certainly don't need the nebular
hypothesis for every little
solid object that's out there as a
biologist i've been working in labs with
a centrifugal
machine we were putting mixes
of matter in this that was coming let's
say a all
animal just or tissue coming from a
plant or something
you put it in there and the machine just
turns around very fast
at some centrifugal force you get
differentiation and that
the most heavy elements will come to the
bottom of your little tube
and the lightest elements will stay at
the top and you can see actual layers
developing
no matter what the weight of these
molecules were they will sort themselves
out in terms of weight couldn't couldn't
it be the same that explains
the differentiation of layers in planets
again uh the big problem there is that
we have moons
next to jupiter solid moons and for
to say that all these moons came from
abroad that somehow
they were thrown into jupiter well
that's not the nebular hypothesis the
nebular hypothesis that all the objects
here in the solar system were created by
a cloud
and the question is if that's the case
you cannot have
a rocky moon like ganymede or any other
galilean
moons next to a gaseous planet like
jupiter
that's that's going to be hard to
explain
and they never have wonderful check my
sixth
sense 10 bucks thank you so much he says
thoughts on dark matter
well we've talked talked about it in in
previous shows i think but you can give
us a summary bill of your position on
dark matter
very simple very very simple under the
general relativity version it's it's
simply a
dark matter is simply a variable in an
equation that's all it is
they've turned that uh value
into something called dark matter nobody
can see it it's very heavy
you know it's a spirit a very a very fat
spirit that's what it is
under the rope model very simple think
of a spider web that's
rotating so we have a rotating spider
web
all stars are interconnected physically
interconnected
every atom is connected to every atom so
every star is connected to every star
that's why stars don't fly out of the
solar out of the
galaxy and that's why the stars on the
outside
travel just as fast or faster than the
ones on the inside because it's a road
it's a carousel
that's what a galaxy is it's all tied
together
so we have a physical interpretation
these people don't have a physical
interpretation they're looking for a
ghost out there they're saying
there's mass out there we can explain it
with mass
but the explanation relies on
a concept on mass how does mass
pull on a star that's what i want to
know
and they and they don't have an
explanation for that they just say we're
looking for some matter out there that
weighs a lot
that's it and it gives job security to
astronomers all right let's finished
on one last subject which was the the
claim of
owen benjamin about nukes not existing
uh how do you convince yourself bill
that nuclear bombs exist do you believe
in nuclear bombs
do you believe they were detonated on
japan
yeah i mean uh all you got to do is go
to hiroshima and nagasaki and
ask those people there you know if
anyone are still around
or their children or whatever did that
ever happen
you know and i think they'll say yeah it
did happen
in fact uh it's very hard to believe
that all these
countries you know india has the bomb
pakistan has the bomb
uh north korea has the bomb you know all
these countries have the bomb and
uh you know to say that all of them are
lying
on top of it we have video of my
understanding is there are videos out
there of
nuclear tests right well those are made
in hollywood you know
okay
all right well let's see the results of
our survey of tonight
is owen benjamin and not jobs 17 people
answer yes four people answer no
we have a majority concluding that he is
devastating on these subjects but what
do you expect
he's a comedian
all right yeah a joker
and this launches me to the subject of
the next show
so uh dear audience join me in the video
that will just show up in maybe 10
minutes
uh i will be making the thumbnail and
title
and let's start it tonight at 9 00 pm
eastern time so that i get a 30 minutes
break
i'm going to be giving my opinion on the
joker
join me tonight on my channel brigade
was there anything else you wanted to
discuss
before we conclude no no no i think
we covered a lot of subjects um the only
thing i would say is that you know
people should look at the rope model if
they want to get a
physical interpretation it doesn't mean
that they're going to believe the rope
that's not the point the point is
do you understand it if you understand
it i've accomplished my goal
absolutely i mean i'm stunned by this
model despite my
my kind of instinct that wanting to
reject stuff like this
it is uh very insightful on so many
things that
it would be surprising that it it's not
it doesn't have
any sort of value i think it's very
impressive
so go watch the billgate channel it's on
youtube the description
is in the link below bill gate i will
see you again in the future
and to our audience join me in 30
minutes
on my channel i will start an
independent video
let's talk about the joker movie bye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you